[Music]
there is a rhythm to life these days in
hakeev
it is the ghastly rhythm of sirens and
of war
each day is similar
explosions billowing smoke and the fear
of what has been hit this time
on this occasion it is a light
industrial area close to the center of
the city
it is one of five attacks we counted in
one day
all slowly burn away at the fabric of a
community destroying the infrastructure
demoralizing the people this is what
it's like in kharkiv every day now
rocket fire shell fire several times a
day causing untold damage here
in the local hospital they treat the
victims of these attacks in the corridor
partly because they're so busy mainly
because they want to keep them away from
the windows in case this place too is
hit
shrapnel shattered this man's shoulder
when a missile hit a market in kharkiv
i'm a kind man he told me but i don't
want the people who did this to live
and this council worker has been shelled
three times in the city helping people
board up windows the fragments went
straight through the bone he says
[Music]
we go back to meet father victor
we last saw him just before the war
sending off troops to their unknown fate
[Music]
he said he would stay with his people
and he has been good to his word
now two months on in their fight against
the invaders he is comforting and
reassuring and encouraging the soldiers
here
and beneath all the calm and aside from
all the prayers he has nothing but
contempt for vladimir putin
i have deep contempt and disgust for him
he says it's surprising there is
something absolutely satanic in human
form
and the goal of these people putin and
his soldiers is to wipe us out
the meaning of their existence
is to destroy
despite all the damage here there is
also defiance they are not losing this
conflict they have their victories and
their spoils of war
erasing the symbols of the enemy is one
thing ridding the country of the enemy
itself
altogether different
mark austin sky news hakeev